it's a concern everywhere really in the
valley homeless encampments and now
another area of town is going to be
cracking down on them eight news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough explains
Henderson's new ordinance
the revitalization efforts here on Water
Street continue but business owners
sharing with me the impact the homeless
have made over recent years and those at
this week's city council meeting not
holding back Suffocation in front of my
business there's litter there's damage
there's fires in an empty home behind my
business Kyle Duffy owner of Little
Chapel on the corner expressing his
frustration I will tell you I have had
overwhelming response from residents and
business owners supporting this
legislation the city of Henderson
passing a new camping ordinance that
would deter the homeless from setting up
camp in public places and rights of way
Carrie Halliday has owned downtown
sewing machine company for 15 years and
she says the homeless issues impact her
work at one point they were camping so
bad that people are like what they
didn't want to bring their kids down and
walk by because they're just there some
of them are very harmless you know but
they're around and they're usually on
drugs a lot of them are homeless because
they have mental illness people not in
compliance of the ordinance could face
six months in jail and or up to a
thousand dollar fine per violation but a
key aspect to the new bill is first
providing help and it isn't until an
individual refuses to go to an available
shelter that a citation or an arrest can
be made Henderson mayor Michelle Romero
is not criminalizing it it's putting all
of the pieces together to address this
situation that has grown worse over time
in Henderson we didn't used to have this
problem
now in 2021 Henderson launched its
homeless response team and so far it's
received about 300 service calls but now
this new camping ordinance is similar to
what the city of Las Vegas is doing
where it's a misdemeanor to Camp or
sleep in the public right-of-way